Brasilia es una ciudad en vilo las
autoridades han investigado dos amenazas
de bomba en el lapso de unos pocos días
y la policía de la capital ha sido
puesta en alerta máxima antes de la toma
de posesión de Lula Silva el 1 de enero
a la que se espera que asistan cientos
de miles de personas
habrá una movilización del 100% de las
fuerzas policiales del Distrito Federal
de Brasilia tanto de la Policía Militar
como de la policía civil y el cuerpo de
bomberos para garantizar la seguridad no
solo el presidente sino también de las
delegaciones extranjeras y el público
el ministro de Justicia entrante también
dijo que intentaría suspender el porte
de armas de fuego en la capital por
parte de los ciudadanos hasta después de
la toma de Posesión el número de
propietarios de armas registrados se han
multiplicado por seis en Brasil desde
que Jair bolsonaro comenzó a
flexibilizar las leyes de portación en
2019 el 24 de diciembre la policía dijo
que había frustrado un complot con bomba
arrestando un negacionista de las
elecciones Pro bolsonaro que dijo que se
inspiró para construir un Arsenal por el
llamado a las armas del presidente
saliente
el sospechoso declaró que usaría clubes
de tiro como fachada para el contrabando
de un poderoso Arsenal
esta semana vamos a enviar al presidente
electo el primer borrador de un decreto
que traería controles más efectivos
después de que Lula venciera Por poco a
bolsonaro con el 50,9% de los votos en
una segunda vuelta electoral en octubre
Los partidarios del presidente Derrotado
bloquearon carreteras y acamparon
cuarteles militares instando el ejército
anular la victoria de Lula
a principios de este mes algunos
manifestantes Pro bolsa Nano también
incendiaron vehículos se enfrentaron a
la policía a intentaron invadir sus
cuarteles y el propio bolsonarok ha
limitado sus apariciones públicas desde
su derrota